[Applause]
jazak for your patience listening now we
have the presumably more interesting
session the question and answer
session as you prepare your questions
for Dr zaker and line up at the three
mics we have provided for you in the
ground one on my left in the front for
the gents one in the
rear on my left for the gents and one in
the ladies section in the rare on my
right for the ladies may I mention a
short message of Dr Zakir on occasion of
this conference in context of Peace TV
he tells my dear brothers and sisters in
Islam and
Humanity assalam alikum may peace be on
you I welcome you to Shar in peace TV's
Global
mission and vision of creating a better
awareness and understanding of Islam as
a
just righteous and peaceful way of life
for the entire
Humanity share in removing
misconceptions false fear and hate of
Islam and Muslims globally this also is
the focus of this
conference now as peace TV is telecast
to over 150 countries
worldwide it
beckons your tawa spirit and support to
make it a household TV channel across
the
globe in all continents
where it is being broadcast presently
except for South
America not only in the Muslim homes but
also in millions of non-muslim homes
seeking reliable Islamic knowledge and
wisdom which many a time is not
available in the mainstream
media now we start the question and
answer
session to generate more value from the
time available for our question and
answer session the following rules need
to be observed by the questioners your
questions must be on the topic is the
Quran God's
word your question should be brief and
to the point you may ask only one
question at a time for your second
question you need to queue again at the
back of the queue where you're
standing questions on the mic will be
given first preference
and if time permits questions on slips
would be given second
preference
non-muslims brothers and sisters will be
given first preference to put forward
their questions to Dr
zaker this would be tackled and handled
by our volunteers at the question
mics then only would our Muslim brothers
and sisters be given questions
preference for asking questions to Dr
Zakir questions would be allowed only
from the mics these questions would be
allowed in a clockwise
rotation first for the ladies the second
for the gents third for the gents again
for the ladies gents and then for the
gents if you
have your questions kindly put it
forward now to Dr Zakir remember three
points on the topic brief and only one
at a time we'll allow the first question
for the ladies the second year the third
at the rare yes
sister okay I have one question in the S
Alam Ron verse
50 it says to follow the teachings of
Jesus why doesn't anyone do
this can you mention your name sister
please chassid
sisters asked a question that the Quran
says in Surah Imran chapter 3 verse
number 50 that we have to follow the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and there are many verses which say
that we have to believe in Jesus peace
be upon Him Sister let me
clarify that Islam is the only
non-Christian Faith which makes it an
Article of Faith to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him no muslim is a
Muslim if he does not believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him
we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala we believe that he was the
Messiah transed Christ we believe that
he was born miraculously without any
male Intervention which many modern
Christians today do not believe we
believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's
permission we believe that he healed
those born blind and lepers with God's
permission the Christian and the Muslim
sister we are going together but one may
ask
where is The Parting of ways The Parting
of ways is sister that many Christians
they say that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he claimed Divinity he said that he
was almighty
God if you read the Bible sister there
is not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that I am
God always say worship
me if any Christian can point out a
single Un IAL statement a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or where he
says worship me I ready to accept
Christianity Today I am not speaking on
behalf of my other Muslim
Brothers in fact if you read the Bible
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 28 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said my father
is greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than all Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse number 28 I cast
out Devil with the spirit of God Gospel
of Luke chapter number 11 verse number
20 I cast out Devil with the Finger of
God Gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of almighty
God but the will of my father anyone who
says that I followed not my will but the
will of almighty God he's a Muslim Jesus
Christ peace be upon you as a Muslim he
never claimed Divinity and it's clearly
mentioned in the book of Acts chapter
number two verse number 22 imen of
Israel listen to this Jesus of Nazareth
a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by him and you are witness to it
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst You by wonders and miracles
which God did B and you witness to it so
we believe that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him he was one one of the mightiest
messengers of God but he was not
God so here we differ as far as the
teachings are concerned your basic
question was that Quran says you have to
follow the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him when Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him came in this world he
was only sent for the Jews only for bani
Israel the Quran says
clearly in Surah saf chapter number 61
verse number six that Jesus peace be
upon Him came as a messenger to the bani
Israel it's mentioned Sur Al Imran
chapter number 3: 49 that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was sent only for the
B Israel it's mentioned in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 10 verse number
five and six Jesus C peace be upon him
he says go not into the way of the
Gentiles who are the Gentiles non-jews
Hindus Muslims going not in the way of
the Gentiles entering not into the city
of the Samaritans but rather go to the
house of the lordship of Israel and a
similar message repeated in the gospel
of Matthew chapter number 15 verse
number 24 he says to his Apostles that I
have been sent not but to the lordship
of the House of Israel so Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was sent only for the
ban Israel and his message was supposed
to be followed only for a particular
time period that's what the Bible says
that's what the Quran says in spite of
this
sister if you read the Bible what Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says if you
analyze it's mentioned in the Gospel of
Luke that Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he was circumcised on the eth
day we Muslim masallah we are
circumcised majority of the Christians
aren't circumcised so if you say that
following the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him makes you a Christian
then I like to say that I'm more
Christian than the Christian themselves
it is mentioned in the
Bible
in the book of Ephesians chapter number
five verse number 18 that be not drunk
It's mentioned the Book of Proverbs
Chapter number 20 verse number one that
wine is a mocker we Muslims we don't
drink alcohol Quran says in Surah ma
chapter number 5 vers number 90 alcohol
is Haram we don't touch it we don't
touch it as a whole the Muslims are the
biggest community of te
tolers so according to the Bible you
should not have alcohol it's mention in
the Bible that you should not have poke
in several places it's mentioned in the
Book of Leviticus chapter number 11
verse number 7 and 8 it's mention the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 14
verse number 8 in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 65 vers number 2 to5 no
less than five places that you should
not have
poke we Muslims we don't have poke but
majority of the Christians they have
poke so if Christian means a person who
follows the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him we Muslims are more
Christian than the Christians
I can go on and on when Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was asked that which
is the first of The Commandments he
mentioned in the gospel of
Mark chapter number 12 verse number 29
he
said it's a Hebrew quotation which means
is the Lord our God is one Lord we
Muslim masallah we believe in none but
one God majority of the Christian they
believe in
Trinity Father Son and Holy
Ghost so if you say
Christian means the person who follows
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him we Muslims are more Christian
than the Christian themselves and you
can refer to my video cassette
similarities between Islam and
Christianity which will give you more
details that we are following more of
the Bibles the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him than the Christian
themselves hope that answers the
question is
sister may I request our questioners to
kindly State their names and profession
so that we get a clear context with what
background they're asking their question
and Zakir can uh inshallah give you a
more appropriate
response and uh we would request our
volunteers to kindly see that very
courteously the non-muslim brothers and
sisters are given the first preference
may I put this to also in context the
objective is the brothers this is an
open question a session and you can feel
free to ask any questions on the topic
of the
day and you are totally free to
criticize Islam attack Islam if Dr Zakir
is speaking anything which is wrong or
not speaking appropriate to the context
of peace or what the message of Islam
States and it is against the basic
Humanity feel free to ask him you are
under a full prot protection and we
appreciate a person who would criticize
us openly in a context like this than a
person who would be against and feel bad
in the heart and not come out in the
open about what we feel we want you to
come out in the open ask questions
criticize attack Dr Zakir this is your
opportunity please don't miss it now
this is your opportunity for the next
one hour feel free to ask question yes
brother assalam alikum my name is is
Ludovic Bonia I am French
non-muslim and uh I am traveling eight
months in India I uh am 18 years old I
compell my 12 in June and so uh inshah
if you agree I will meet you in private
but now uh I just would like to ask you
um about the Jews U maybe if I am not
wrong you said that uh it is written in
the Quran that Jews and Pion are
the uh Str uh strong enemies of
Believers Muslim Believers Muslim and uh
I would like to know how this verse can
favoritee peace in uh in hum
kind uh when we see the troubles between
Palestine and Israel uh how some Muslim
and some Jews can uh cannot be cannot
misunderstand this verse because maybe
it can uh provoke uh it can provoke some
uh Mis Mis interpretation or if it's rly
that uh Jews and Muslim have to be
enemies brother that's a good question
that he said I said in my speech and
Accord to the verse of the Quran of Sur
ma 5: 82 which says that strongest in
enmity to the Muslims would be the Jews
and the pagans and the closest In Love
would be the Christians so he say won't
it create enemity when they say that the
Jews and the Muslim should fight the
Quran doesn't say Jews and the Muslim
should fight the Quran says strongest in
enmity to the Muslims to the Believers
will be Jews it does not say that
Muslims should fight with the Jews it
doesn't say that but it says that the
Jews by Nature as a
whole they'll be against Muslims and I
told him my leure there are many Jews
who accepted Islam there are many Jews
who are good to Muslims but as a whole
as a whole if you take Jews as a whole
and the Christians as a whole the
Christians are closer than the Jews as a
whole this is a
fact for example the Quran says that the
Jews are intelligent also
that's a fact if the intelligent
intelligent that doesn't mean that it
hides the fact and the Quran also says
that they will be as a whole a stous
enemy so this is one of the
falsification test that today if you
want to prove the Quran wrong if the
Jews the Jews get together all of them
and they decide let let's prove the
Quran wrong at least for 3 four years we
will be better than the Christians let's
stop the war of Palestine you know the
Palestinians the Jews were kicked out by
Hitler Hitler insuated 6 million Jews he
kicked them out of
Germany the Arabs the Palestinians they
do Alan veran come with open
arms after a few years they kicked out
of the
home imagine someone gives a traveler
his home to live and the traveler kicks
him out of his home and he's shouting
that he has taken my house and you're
calling them
terrorists so what they have to do is
let's get together and solve this
problem whatever the problem is today
America is controlled by the Jews
whether it be the banks whether it be
the money whether it be the power
according to the American survey no one
can become a president of USA without
walking the Star of
David though the Jews are a minority
less than 5% in America but they're
controlling the economy they're
controlling
America fine so are controlling America
let all of these lets solve the problem
of Palestine let solve the American
problem not forever few
years four five years only and the
problem is Sol so we aren't telling that
the Muslim should fight with the Jews in
fact the Quran says even if your enemy
want peace several places even if they
come to fight you it's mentioned Sur
anal in the battle if they want peace
give it to them so Quran is always for
peace Quran is always encouraging them
but if a person does not want peace
peace to Prevail what can we do Islam is
a religion of Peace it wants peace but
it even mentioned
facts that means we have to be careful
of the Jews not that we have to fight
them unless they come and fight with you
that's a different thing imagine what's
happening in Palestine what's happening
other parts of the world so brother for
peace to Prevail you have to follow the
guidance of the Quran and live
harmoniously rather than be enemies so
Quran doesn't say that Jews should be
enemies but they will be saying hope
that answer the
question can we have the next question
from the brother in the
r i Mr
Chan uh retired teacher before question
I would like to Salam all of
you my question
is the Quran is word of God as you
propounded in uh
detail several but I doubt that Quran is
not only the word of God but it is
mixture of God's and prophet's word how
because in several verses you said you
mention that uh I have not written as
Prophet mentioning that I have not
written it is not my word wherever he
has clarified that it is not my my work
so what about these words these are not
his words
please brother asked a very good
question and that logic I use when I
speak to the Christians about the Bible
the brother said that undoubtedly you
proved it the word of God but besides
being the word of God there's words of
prophet because it's mentioned in the
Quran I did not write
it brother no verse of the Quran says I
did not write it you point out the the
verse and I'll accept that the Quran is
not the word of
God what does the Quran say they say
that the prophet wrote it and I quoted
maybe you misheard me what I said that
Sur s chapter number 32 verse number 1
to3 they say that the prophet forged it
tell them n it is the truth from
almighty God it is almighty God talking
if the prophet wrote it then I agree
with you this this is what is mentioned
in the Bible in the Bible it says that
Moses peace be upon him he
says that I
died on so and so neither Moses wrote it
neither God wrote it so Moses wrote the
book how can you say that I
died so that's what you find in the
Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
speaking so what do we say as far as the
Quran is concerned never will you find
any direct speech of the prophet if it
is it is quoted by almighty God in
inverted Commerce almighty God may say
that the prophet replied but never does
the Quran say I did not write
it in fact the Quran says it is from
almighty God and I quoted several verses
if you want me to repeat I can repeat
again Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse
number 19 Surah Anam chapter number 6
verse number 93 Surah Yu chapter number
12 verse number 1 and 2 in Surah CH
number 20 vers number 113 in Sur s 32
vers number 1 to3 in Surah Yin chter
number 3 vers number 1 to 3 in Sur Z
chter number 39 vers number one in Sur
CH 40 vers number 2 in Surah Yasha CH 45
vers number two several places the Quran
says this book is a revelation from
almighty God direct
speech hope to answer the
question yes
sister hi my name is Sarah I'm a
independent student I graduated America
I'm here studying independently um as
you have stated Jesus never does claim
Divinity in the Bible in Revelation
chapter 1 I can't read the whole chapter
because it would take a very long time
but Jesus is speaking and he says do not
be afraid I am the first and the last I
am the living one I was dead and behold
I am alive forever and ever I hold the
keys of death and Hades he also says I
am the Alpha and the Omega who is and
who was and who is to come the almighty
these are also names of God written in
the Old and New Testament and I don't
see how that does not show that Jesus is
not genetically the Son of God but
spiritually the son of God the S asked
her question she quoted Revelation
chapter number one she didn't give the
verses she's talking about the first 20
verses and I'm Alpha and Omega is verse
number 11 Revelation chapter number one
verse number 11 where Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him says that I'm Alpha and
Omega so she says just because Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says I'm Alpha
and Omega I'm first and the last
according to you he's claiming Divinity
Mark me I had said there is not a single
unequal loal statement not a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or where he
say worship me he didn't say now you are
saying that because Jesus said I'm Alpha
and Omega therefore he's almighty God
what do you mean Alpha and Omega I'm the
first and the last in what do you mean
Jesus Christ was first in this world no
he was born in a stable before him was
his mother there were many prophets that
came before him so surely he's not the
first
neither is he the last in the Bible it
says Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he'll be coming it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12 to 14 I have many things to
say unto you but he cannot bear them now
for he when the spirit of truth shall
come he shall guide you unto all tro he
shall not speak of himself all that he
year shall he speak he shall glorify me
he shall show you things to come talking
about Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
so what does this word alpha and omega
mean it does not mean that he first and
the last Act actually
literally because there were many people
who came before him and there many
people who came after him what does it
mean that in the law of
God whatever the messenger says the law
of God is first and last at the time of
Moses Moses was alpha and omega as far
as the law of God was concerned whatever
he taught had to be followed at the time
of Jesus Jesus Christ peace be upon him
his teachings were Alpha and Omega it
had to be followed at the time of
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him his
teachings are alpha and omega it is the
first and the
last it does not mean that he claimed
Divinity so therefore I said any
unambiguous statement if you literally
mean you first and last if you read the
Bible the Bible disagrees there were
many people who came before Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he was born in the
womb of the mother and various people
came after him also so surely sister
therefore I said unambiguous unequivocal
statement hope that anwers the question
yes brother my name is Aran arra Kumar
Naran Singh K from
D I speak no continue English to English
I'm very very
sorry
is
the brothers asked two questions the
first question is can there be changed
in the law and the teachings of almighty
God can there be changes and question
two is that can a person be
reborn can he be reborn and he quoted a
verse of the Gita which I'll come to it
later on as far as the first question is
concerned can and the laws of God keep
on changing if the law of God is time
bound if it's meant for only a
particular group of people and for a
particular time period it will keep on
changing for example as I mentioned my
talk tah zabur injil all of them were
revelation of God but they were meant
for a particular group of people and for
a particular time
period but once the last and final
revelation of God has been revealed
nothing new can be
added nothing can be subtracted
Quran is the last and final revelation
of almighty God no other Revelation is
going to come Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the last and final messenger
there is no other Messenger to come
Allah says inah 30 verse number
40 that Muhammad peace be upon Him is
not the father of any of you men but he
is the messenger of Allah and the F of
the prophets and Allah is all knowing
full ofice wisdom after Prophet Muhammad
if anyone says that he is a messenger of
God he gets Revelation then he requires
a
psychiatrist Prophet Muhammad is the
last and final messenger after Quran no
other Revelation going to come and Quran
clearly mentioned in Sur 5 vers number
three on this day have I complete my
religion for you and I've chosen for you
Islam and complete my favor on you once
the religion is completed nothing new
can be added nothing can be subtracted
so as far your question yes the old
Revelations there can be changes but the
basic message from the first revelation
till the last about about Oneness of God
is the same so all the revelations that
came before the Quran they have not
maintained the pure form they have been
changed by human beings and because it
was not meant for eternity almighty God
didn't feel it fit to be preserved but
as far as the Quran is concerned Allah
says in Surah chapter number 15 vers
number nine we have revealed the Quran
and we shall guard it from
corruption this Quran even if all the
human beings try and change the Quran
they cannot do
it all the human being and Jin they get
together they can't change the Quran so
as far as the previous Revelation yes
there can be a change but the final
Revelation no it cannot be changed it is
the
ultimate now coming to your second
question no second question here sir the
second question
m
inshah the asked another new question so
I told him first to the old question
then I'll come to a new question his
previous question was that do you
believe in reincarnation in a second
life as far as reincarnation is
concerned what you quoted is bhagwat
Gita but the highest scripture in
Hinduism is V vas are number
one they are the
shis then later on come the smis
Mahabharat part of Mahabharat is bhagat
Gita though bhagat Gita is more widely
read Than The Vedas but authenticity in
grade Veda is higher the V speaks about
Punam Punam mean next life and if you
read the Quran the Quran too speaks
about next life Quran says you'll come
in this world you'll die again you'll be
resurrected punar means next Janam means
life pun Janam nowhere does the V speaks
about death Life Death Life Death Life
Death life
nowhere nowhere
neither does the bhagat Gita speak about
that what you quoted to me is a verse of
bhagad Gita chapter number four verse
number
22 I'm giving you the
reference where it's mentioned in
bhagwat Gita according to the Hindus
it's a word of almighty God and it says
that as the human beings keep on
changing the clothes they throw away the
old clothes and put on new clothes same
way the soul will take a new body we
throw away the old body new body I have
got no problem in this world you have
this body when you die you are rejected
new body no problem it is matching with
the Quran matching with the
Veda but this philosophy what you're
talking about reincarnation in Sanskrit
it is called as
Samara the theory of reincarnation the
theory of life and death called as
rebirth correct now this theory was
propounded by the scholars of Hinduism
it's nowhere mentioned in the Vas
why because they could not justify some
people are born deaf some people born
rich some people born in a poor family
some people are unhealthy some people
conal heart disease how can God be
unjust so they couldn't justify so they
came with the philosophy of death Life
Death life Karma and Dharma karma is the
deed action Dharma is the law so what
justification how can God be unjust how
can a person be born with the heart
disease ah last life he did some sin
this was a philosophy assumption by the
scholars of Hinduism not
by so then they came with this
philosophy and they say that if you do
good deeds in your next life you'll be
born of a higher
degree and the universal breath out of
Hinduism is all living creatures are bre
so maybe you're born sometime as a
cockroach sometime as a rat sometime as
a cat sometime as a dog sometime as
human being human being is the highest
level so if you do good deeds you're
born higher if you do bad Deeds you're
born lower fine and you're born as a
human being seven times how many times
seven the philosophy of the Hindu
Scholars called as samsar now I'm asking
you a question brother in this world sin
is increasing or
decreasing
sin mashallah very good sin is
increasing population of human being
insan so sin is also increasing and
human beings are
increasing if sin is increasing human
beings should
decrease so what we realize logically
it's not correct therefore I believe in
pun Janam Punam is next life speaks
about next life but only one you come in
this world only once now coming to your
third question about
Brahma
Vishnu mahes or Shiva same same two
names mahes and sha same but more
popular Shiva right the Creator the
Destroyer the sustainer Brahma Vishnu
Shiva and you ask me that does God have
these three forms no God doesn't have
three forms does he have any people yes
he has many angels see alone God is
sufficient he does not require anyone's
help but if he wants he can do it
through an angel if he wants if he
doesn't want no problem he just wills
and it is be and it is as far as the
Hindus what they believe they believe in
somewhat similar Trinity what the
Christians believe even the Hindus
believe that almighty God one God is God
to create Brahma one God is God to
destroy Shiva one God is God to sustain
Vishnu the separate God for creation
separate God for sustaining separate God
for
destroying the Quran
says in Surah Ambia chter 21 verse
number 22 if there were Gods more than
one God surely they would have fought
among
themselves and Quran says in Surah
chapter number 23 verse number 91 that
if there were many gods they would have
piled upon one another and that's what
we find Hindu mythology one God fighting
with the other God one God defeating the
other God third God helping the second
God how can Gods fight so best is only
one God super power is only one and that
is what the vi says if you ask a common
Hindu how many gods does he believe in
some will say three some will say 100
some will say thousand some will say 33
crores 330 million but if you ask a
learned Hindu that how many gods should
a Hindu believe in he will tell you
Hindu should believe only in one
God but but the common Hindu he believed
in a philosophy known as pantheism what
he says that everything is God the Tre
is God the sun is God the Moon is God
the human being is God and the snake is
God what we Muslims
say everything is God's g o d with an
apostrophe everything belongs to God the
tree belongs to God the sun belongs to
God the moon belongs to God the human
being belongs to God as well as this
thing belongs to God so the major
difference between the Hindus and the
Muslims is the Hindus say everything is
God we Muslims say everything is gods g
with apostrophes the major difference is
apostrophes if we can solve this
difference of apostrophes the Hindus and
the Muslims will be
United how do we do
it Allah says in the Quran in Iman
chapter number 3 verse number
64 come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we Associated to partners
with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and P other than Allah if then
they turn
back say we bear witness that we are
Muslims bowing our to Allah subhana tala
the best way to analyze any religion is
not to try and understand what the
followers are doing but you have to
analyze the scriptures now if we analyze
Hindu scriptures if we read the
upanishads which V upanishad the highest
it's
mentioned chapter number six section
number two verse number
one God is only one without a second it
a Sanskrit
quotation God is only one without a
second it's mentioned
in chapter number six verse number
n of him there is no God he has got no
parents almighty God has got no Superior
he has got no mother he has got no
father it's mentioned in thean chapter
number four verse number
19 of that God there is no pratima
pratima means image pratima means
photograph Idol sculpture painting
almighty God has got no photograph has
got no sculptures has got no statue has
got no painting he has got no
images and amongst the Hindu scriptures
the most sacred are the V it's mentioned
chapter number 32 verse number
three of that almighty God there is no
pratima there is no images there is no
photograph there is no sculpture there's
no statue it's mentioned chapter number
40 verse number 8 almighty God is pure
it's mentioned 40 verse number
n they entering Darkness those who
worship the asui asamu are the natural
things like fire water air Etc and the
verse continues they are entering more
in darkness those who worship the STI
STI are the created things like table
chair idle Etc who says that yaj chter
40 verse number n and the Brahma Sutra
of Hinduism
isah there is only one God not a second
one not at all not at all not in the
least
B uh we' like our audience to to give
this young boy a good hand because I
think when we are young we are more
innocent we are more righteous we are
more truthful he's an example of it
putting a very genuine question he had a
genuine question he believed in a
genuine approach alhamdulillah uh may we
have the next question from the brother
in the
back